the packers have paid aaron rodgers a
lot aaron rodgers still isn't happy
aaron rodgers is happy to be in hawaii
but he's not happy with the packers
peter it was monday night where aaron
rodgers spoke to kenny mayne and finally
launched into this monologue over it's
all about the people
whatever
i think most people look at that and say
that's really not what's going on here
this isn't aaron's concern about about
the people it's about
the person it's about how he's been
treated
and look i talked to some folks
yesterday about this
the the ice is
still
in place no thaw
rogers doesn't want to come back
packers aren't going to budge
i don't know where this is gonna go
i don't either but when watching that
the other day you know in the past of
aggressive rogers
uh basically uh saying i love everybody
in green bay except brian gutenstein
maybe mark murphy or you know that's
what it sounded like to me
um i look
the thing we still don't know mike we
know that aaron rodgers wants out in in
a bad way we know that you know we don't
know
we don't know what's going to happen if
on august 15th
aaron rodgers hasn't been traded
you know what's he going to do is he
going to continue to take 50 000 a day
fine for missing training camp i mean if
he doesn't go to training camp that's
two million dollars that cannot be
erased
and
so you start looking at things like that
and you start to say okay is this an
absolutely rock solid i am not going
back
if it's that it's going to cost him a
lot of money
and
apparently and i've never thought aaron
rodgers was uh i need every last dollar
i i've never thought of him in that way
at all
but
to me
i've thought that there's either that
part of it
or what happens
between now and
july 15th let's just say
if jeopardy says
aaron we want you to be the the host
for our next season for our 21-22 season
but we want you here
exclusively i mean the condition of the
job is you got to be here
i won't be shocked if aaron rodgers
takes a year off from football
now and then we'll see what happens in
the future
but the way i look at this right now
mike i agree with you i have no idea
what's going to happen
i bet the packers don't either
well and you mentioned august 15 with
the implication that he's held out and
incurred that fifty thousand dollar per
day fine which by rule now under the cba
for anyone in the second contract or
beyond cannot be waived cannot be wiped
off the books like we've seen in the
past where the team doesn't publicize
but like when heinz ward held out and
racked up a bunch of fines he went back
and the steelers are like we're just not
gonna we're not gonna collect that you
can't do that now for anyone not
operating under his rookie contract so
like you said two million is gone i
think he would announce his retirement
in lieu of holding out if it comes down
to it now if he retires and sits out all
year he's looking at 11.5 million in
signing bonus money that gets paid back
he's got 6.8 million in a roster bonus
he's already earned that would get paid
back he's got 14.7 million in salary
that he'll never earn and it's one less
year
that he has left before father time
finally catches him and prevents him
from playing at a high level do you want
to squander a year of football or will
you just say
i am reluctantly coming back because i
love my teammates i love my coaches i
love the fans and i hate everybody else
i'm coming back for them because i feel
like that's what he's setting up peter
he doesn't want to be the pariah like
farv was when he left he wants the fans
on his side so he's on record i love the
fans i love my teammates i love my
coaches i think it's harder for him to
to give them the middle finger by giving
the middle finger to the front office
because they get caught in the middle of
it and they're the ones who are harmed
by the reigning mvp not being there so
i'm i'm still leaning on the side of he
finds a way to show up and blame the
media for making it a big deal
i don't know i mean mike
i i've looked at this this way all along
that
you know today is whatever it is uh may
28th and
you know there's a lot of difference
between may 28th and july 28th two
months is a long time
and there are times for feelings to
harden and there are times for feelings
to soften
and in my opinion i don't think aaron
rodgers is going to get friendly with
the front office of the green bay
packers
but
you then have to ask yourself
if you're aaron rodgers what's my best
option
is my best option to say
i'm retiring is my best option to say
i'm a hold out i'm simply not playing
what is my best option
and then you have to make a decision
i think by late july i don't think he
really has to do anything for the next
two months it's pretty clear that he
won't go to the mandatory mini camp
he'll just take the fine for that
but two months from now
is when everyone really has to know
and you know the nfl teams will be going
to camp i believe the packers reporting
date is going to be july 27th so that's
exactly two months away so i think there
are two months
for
all reporters in the state of wisconsin
to not be able to take vacation
because
i mean really
we have absolutely no idea
what the next step in this drama is
going to be
and and one very real factor here and i
like to stay away from these things
generally but it is a factor
the new relationship you have a new
individual in your life who has
influence over you that's the way the
world works that's what broke up the
beatles for crying out loud and
and i know that there's at least some
thought
in green bay that
how is he being influenced and what is
he being told and how is
he being i don't want to say manipulated
but it's just the reality when you have
a new partner in your life
and you're engaged
that voice
resonates
and i think the packers are leery about
that unknown as well
and i i just think that the packers
don't know what the hell is going to
happen
they aren't going to trade him now of
course we've heard that before and i've
said pay no attention to the man behind
the curtain because a lot of times
that's said for leverage but look peter
they don't need to create leverage here
they're never going to get more for
aaron rodgers
ever than they're going to get right now
unless he comes back and has another mvp
season and wins the super bowl they're
never getting more for him i mean he'll
still be a year older this is the
pinnacle this is the time if you're
going to do it and they're just not
going to do it they want to keep him
period so uh it's gonna it's gonna be
like you said it's it's something where
the folks who cover the team are not
gonna be able to to take a week off much
less a day off because you never know
when we're gonna get the next
development from aaron rodgers
and and i think part of that means mike
that in the next six to eight weeks
that there's going to be much hue and
cry
about
probably about very little because i
think this is going to go right up to
the deadline
um and maybe even beyond the deadline
maybe even into august but i just don't
see anything happening in the next
you know seven or eight weeks because
i just think and you're right about
the impact of shailene woodley on his
life i mean
nobody has any idea what that is anybody
who says they do i'm sure unless they're
close to the family
you know is just rumor mongering so i
have no idea what that's going to be you
have no idea what it's going to be
and i think there are sometimes
you know mike you have maintained
throughout all this aaron rodgers needs
to come clean he needs to say exactly
what he's mad at and what he's angry
about and all this stuff
and
we now
are pretty sure that he's never going to
do that that's not how he does business
whether you like it or whether you don't
like it you're not going to hear from
aaron rodgers my big problem is with
brian gooda constant here's why
you know
and and so we're not that's not who he's
going to be and you have to decide are
you willing to accept
everything
the the entire aaron rodgers package the
passive aggressive aaron rod part of
aaron rodgers the greatness on the field
you know the fact that uh you know he's
got a ton of other interests in life and
he very well may exercise them
so that is the modern aaron rodgers
that's the modern nfl quarterback and we
just have to see where it goes
here's one scenario that i believe the
packers have on their radar screen for
what could happen
we could see a scenario where aaron
rodgers decides to not play
this year
retires for this year pays back a lot of
money misses out on his 14.7 million
salary and then
next year
after the packers have moved on after
the packers have another quarterback
after the packers have turned the page
then he pulls the brett favre
show up out of nowhere deal with me deal
with my cap charge deal with my salary
obligation and hope that at that point
they'll have no choice but to trade him
just like they had no choice but to
trade favre after they had turned the
page to aaron rodgers so that's
something to keep an eye on no football
for rogers in 2021 and then he shows up
out of the blue next year and the
packers at that point
have their hands tied and they have to
move on from it
that could happen
i think
they would want to
almost under any circumstances end the
drama before then
it's it's very hard to have
a most valuable player sort of damocles
hanging over your franchise for
in that in that uh under that scenario
15 14 months
and so
i think it whatever happens it happens
before that moment happens
but you know you mentioned the sword of
damocles and i've used that reference as
it relates to what the packers have done
to rogers and this gets back to why he's
upset and peter
during that
it's all about the people spiel the
other night he said at one point he
threw a wrench into their plans by
winning mvp and that tells me
he believed as of last year when they
traded up in round one didn't wait for
jordan love to fall to them and just
look around and say who else are we
gonna take they made the move up to get
him which has a different vibe to it
then you know it's one thing if tuatanga
vilo had been lingering at 30. no they
jump up to get the guy who's a project
and
rogers believed based upon that comment
that he made to kenny mayne rogers
believed
that their plan was one more year with
aaron and then we move on he threw a
wrench into that by being
the league mvp
and they have been unable to talk him
away from that mindset
now maybe it's the truth maybe he's
right and they're just trying to engage
in damage control but as long as he
believes that that they were going to
move on from him after the 2020 season
then why shouldn't they let me move on
if you were gonna move on from me why
shouldn't i be allowed to move on from
you and therein lies the rub and i think
that may be
the core of this it's not about jordan
love it's about the fact that the
packers hatched a plan that we're gonna
keep aaron for one more year and move on
until he has an mvp season and they're
like we can't get rid of him now
i remember on the sunday
of draft weekend in 2020
i was talking to brian goodakins
and i said
what happens
if basically aaron rodgers pulls a tom
brady
and over the next three or four years
he's not good but he's great and
maybe you he wins an mvp or a couple of
super bowls or whatever because remember
when the patriots drafted jimmy
garoppolo you know in the next four
seasons in the fourth season obviously
in the middle of it the patriots traded
jimmy garoppolo to san francisco for a
second round draft choice
but
in those four years
tom brady won two super bowls and an mvp
so what brady did essentially is he said
i'll show you what happens when you take
a quarterback
i'll show you and it's one of the
reasons why i was really kind of quite
honestly uh you know anti-carson wentz
this year
when it seemed like he said oh okay
you take jalen hurts hey listen you have
a good time with jalen hurts i'm out of
here and my attitude is gonna suck you
know i mean that was that is what i saw
in carson wentz now maybe that's not
entirely the case that's how i read it
but i think in this particular case
i think there's a lot of truth
in what aaron rodgers inferred the other
night that you know he threw a wrench
into the packers plans but let me go
back to goodikins for a second he said
to me that day when i said what if aaron
rodgers does this and you have to pull
a jimmy garoppolo in in four years or
less than four years
and trade jordan love to somebody
and he said
that'll be great for the packers because
that'll mean that we're getting the best
quarter great quarterback play
out of aaron rodgers so that's fine
um now i doubt he deep down
really thought that's what was going to
happen
but in essence
i think they weren't thinking that we're
going to trade aaron rodgers in one year
they thought maybe we'd be trading them
in two years
but i really sincerely doubt that after
one year especially
after jordan love not playing at all
that they then would have said okay
let's trade a really good quarterback
who's got three or four years left
and put a totally unproven guy i can
tell you matt lafleur would not have
been on the side of making that trade
and peter that underscores in my view
the dysfunction that is inherent to the
relationship because and this door
swings both ways
the packers if that's what they were
thinking that we're not going to trade
him after one year
he's still our guy good problem to have
if aaron rodgers ends up playing at a
high level for the next three years or
and we never get anything out of jordan
11 we have to trade him like the
patriots had to trade jimmy garoppolo
three years later you got to talk to the
guy you got to tell the guy you can't
have that that firewall between
management
and labor where you don't explain to the
most important
employee in the entire corporation more
important than anyone else the highest
paid most important most famous person
in the entire green bay packers
incorporated because they have no owner
how can you handle him that way how can
you not have the conversation with him
every step of the way alex smith was on
with colin coward the other day and he
made it clear that the chiefs trusted
him
with the information regarding their top
secret confidential plan to trade up and
get patrick mahomes every step of the
way alex smith knew what was going on
how do you not peter if you're the
packers how do you not make sure that
aaron rodgers is aware of exactly what
you're thinking why you're thinking it
and what you're planning to do unless
you're just fearful number one he's
going to run his mouth and blow up your
plan or number two nothing you say is
gonna matter either way it's
dysfunctional and it makes me wonder why
the packers just don't want this thing
to end the same way rogers wants it to
end
look
you know
it it has been said and so i take it as
fact
um because reliable people have said it
that uh the green bay packers did not
call and inform aaron rodgers of what
was about to happen
uh when they took jordan love
and if that's the case
it's a terrible job by the green bay
packers terrible because you know look
how whether you warn him
uh you know a day in advance or an hour
in advance
you know
you know this is this is far and away
the most important guy in your franchise
and
and you know coach president you know
whatever gm he's the most important guy
in your franchise
and you know
how would you feel if you're aaron
rodgers sitting at home you know
watching the draft and you look and
you're hoping that hey are we going to
trade up and get justin jefferson or or
or whoever
or are we just going to sit there and
take some defensive guy like we always
do
and you know imagine the shock of aaron
rodgers when he sees that they've taken
a quarterback the guy who obviously is
meant to replace him and if that's
indeed what happened
i do not blame him at all
and and knowing rogers a little bit i
don't know him well but knowing rogers a
little bit
i have always thought
he is angrier
that they never told him what they were
going to do or what the plan was what
the plan might be even he's angrier
about that
than he is about the fact that they took
a quarterback
and sims and i talked about this
yesterday peter i think a lot of it
comes down to trust and did they trust
him to be discreet with it or sabotage
it by telling a friend who tells a
friend who tells a friend who tells a
reporter and then the cat's out of the
bag that the packers love jordan love
and
no flag is planted
but all you had to do
an hour before the this is done you
didn't have to tell them three days
before it was done an hour before this
is done
you you basically carve out five minutes
and
you get the coach and the gm who have to
leave their their
spot for a few minutes
and you carve out five minutes it's an
important thing to do and you pick up
the phone you call rogers
that is something that i just think you
had to do and they apparently did not do
and and i i can't help but wonder
whether
they considered it and realized
there's a chance they make it worse
by telling him so late in the hour that
they're doing this because he quite
possibly would respond to that by saying
why am i just finding out about this
plan
right now
why wait a minute you've been thinking
and and there there's the alternative
but the alternative
the alternative
in not saying anything is a lot worse
than than him being ticked off that he
doesn't find out about this until an
hour before it happens you know the
altar
not finding out about it at all
is
obviously something that you know
is really going to
uh get aaron rodgers goat and obviously
it did
and that's why i'm fascinated by this
question of was this just a byproduct of
the ron wolfe mindset that's been baked
into the front office
we run the show you guys just work here
we don't have an obligation to tell you
anything to do anything right you just
you just show up and play football and
they didn't even think about telling him
is that the explanation or is it there
was some
deliberate
discussion strategy they did think about
it they did talk about at the end of the
day they said let's just not
let's not
open that can of worms right now because
that can of worm is going to open anyway
let's just go ahead and do what we have
to do this first round drive because it
is true the this this bubbled up
yesterday and and i talked to somebody
about it and it is absolutely true they
had targeted justin jefferson they
wanted justin jefferson the vikings took
him then they wanted brandon ayuk and
the 49ers jumped up to take brandon iuk
because the 49ers kept their mouths shut
about what they wanted and then the
packers their top two receivers were
gone instead of sliding back and maybe
taking a chase pool
they they decide to take jordan love but
what makes it worse is the thing that is
that that that
shows that it wasn't just something that
fell into their laps they traded up to
get jordan love and maybe they traded up
just because they felt burned by the two
guys they missed out on and they're
thinking we should have just traded up
and we could have gotten i especially
iuk because the patriots traded down at
one point there they could have moved
into that spot instead of i think it was
the chargers who jumped up but maybe
they just jumped up because they didn't
want to be over three for the guys they
wanted but regardless regardless peter
you nailed it they need to call the guy
at some point and when you don't you set
in motion
the dominoes that have brought us to
this point and i feel like there's still
more dominoes you know it's like
watching one of those dominant things
you don't know where the hell it's going
you don't know whether it's going to set
off a rocket whether it's going to drop
into a toilet whatever it's going to do
but we're just watching those dominoes
as they keep falling
i'm sure that the packers it to some
degree would say hey listen we didn't
call jair alexander and kevin king this
year when we took a corner in the first
round we didn't call uh
uh you know we didn't call our talented
group of running backs any of them you
know when we took aj dillon last year
so
and and and i think i think they can be
comfortable in the fact as ron wolf has
elucidated very clearly and pointedly is
that you know ron wolfe has said on on a
couple of occasions now since this is
all
uh exploded
that basically hey listen you know the
quarterback wants to do everything you
know he wants to pick the players he
wants to do this and you know he's
obviously exaggerating but
that is you talk about the ron wolfe
attitude the ron wolf attitude is that
look here's my job my job is to pick the
best players here's the coach's job
coach's job is to coach the players
here's the player's job the player's job
is to play
never the three twain shall meet
well times are changing in the nfl
and if you can't see that by now you
know you've already had a and with an
asterisk obviously desean watson talking
himself out of tech out of houston and
regardless of what happens legally i
don't think he ever takes a snap for the
texans again and and russell wilson
starting to talk that way and tom brady
in a very gentlemanly way
uh basically leaving new england
different story obviously his contract
was up but
you're seeing now quarterbacks get more
and more power and so i think this is
all a part of that
and all a part of okay what would you
rather do would you rather consult with
aaron rodgers even though it might make
you gnash your teeth a little bit grind
your teeth because that goes against
your ultimate philosophy
as a team architect
or
would you like to basically say all
right we're going to keep doing things
exactly the way we've always done them
and make our most important employee
angry to the point that he wants out i
mean i think it's a pretty logical and
simple answer you got to compromise and
you got to be more in tune and in touch
with the people who make your team great
if they truly believe that failing to
tell aaron rodgers that they were going
to draft jordan love is the same as not
consulting with a position player other
than a franchise quarterback and one of
the best to ever play the game
that explains why aaron rodgers wants
out and it's not about the people
generally because under aaron rodgers
monologue from the other night you would
tell jair alexander you would tell aaron
jones no this is about the king of the
hill the king of the north the guy who
stirs the drink for the packers they
disrespected him
and now they are dealing with the same
sense of uncertainty that he made them
or that they made him deal with all of
last year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports